موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قال مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي جيك سلفا انه كانت لبلاده
فرصه لننخراطي في التواصل على مستويات
عليا مع الروس واضاف طالبا في حديث امام
مجلس العلاقات الخارجيه الامريكي ان هدف
هذا التواصل خفض المخاطر وتقليص فرص اي
استخدام المحتمل للاسلحه النوويه وتوضيح
عواقب استخدامها في غضون ذلك قال مستشار
الرئيس الاوكرانيين لم ترفض ابدا التفاوض
مع روسيا وانا موقفها معروف داعيا القوات
الروسيه الى الانسحاب اولا من اوكرانيا
قبل الحديث عن التفاوض واتهام مستشار رئيس
الاوكرانيه الرئيس الروسي بانه غير مستعد
للمفاوضات وقال ان اوكرانيا ستتحدث مع
الرئيس الروسي القادم
من جد قال الكريم لنا روسيا لا تزال
منفتحه على المحادثات مع اوكرانيا
صحيفه الوصل عن اجراء المستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي محادثات سريه مع الجانب
الروسي قال الكريم لاننا وسائل الاعلام
البريطانيه والامريكيه تورد الكثير من ما
وصفها بالمعلومات الكاذبه
يتوجه الناخبون في الولايات المتحده خلال
ساعات الى صناديق الاقتران الادلاء
باصواتهم في الانتخابات النصفيه ويتنافس
الحزبان الجمهوري والديمقراطيه على جميع
مقاعد مجلس النواب البالغي عددها
435 مقعدا وعلى 35 مقعدا من مقاعد مجلس
الشيوخ البالغ عددها 100 مقعد كما يتنافس
الحزبان على 36 منصبا من مناصب حكام
الولايات الخمسين
وخلال التجمع الجماهيريا للحزب الديمقراطي
في ولايه ماريلاند قال الرئيس الامريكي ان
الديمقراطيه الامريكيه معرضه للخطر ويجب
الدفاع عنها وحضر بعيدا من ان العنف
السياسي والترهيب يتزادان في جميع انحاء
الولايات المتحده
اما الرئيس الامريكي السابق دانون
مخاطبا انصاره ضمن فعاليه الانتخابيه في
ان اداره تبادل حولت البلاد الى دوله
بوليسيه
رجل الاعمال الروسيه المقرب من الرئيس
سافلاديمير بوتين ومؤسس مجموعه فاجنر لانه
تدخل في الانتخابات الامريكيه وقال بروجين
في منشور على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لقد
تدخلنا في الانتخابات الامريكيه تدخلنا
ومازلنا نتدخل وسنواصل التدخل
وقالت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه من جانبها
ان اداره الرئيس جوبتا لن تتسهل مع التدخل
في الانتخابات الامريكيه بغض النظر عن
مصدره وقالت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض
انها تصريحاتيه في الرجيم غير جديده وغير
مفاجاه
اعلنت كوريا الشماليه انها سترد على
التدريبات المشتركه بين الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه باتخاذ ما وصفتها
باجراءات عسكريه حازمه وتحدثت عن تنفيذ
طلعات قتاليه شملت 500 طائره
الولايات المتحده مع كوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان على توجيه رساله حاسمه و موحده
ردا على ما وصفته باستفزازاته
[موسيقى]